can you help me get a good definition of
birthing people
i think if we're talking about those who
give birth i think we're talking about
uh he can't say mother because he is
beholden to the radical
view that men can give birth
let's move over to the the people who
give
birth to all sorts of children
we used to call them mothers used to
call them moms
now not so much in the in the
biden budget mothers have been replaced
by the term
birthing people senator lankford
recently asked
xavier becerra the head of hhs
to help him out to figure out that the
definition of this strange new term
i also notice you changed a term in your
budget work
you shifted from in places from using
the term
mother to birthing people rather than
mother
can you help me get a good definition of
birthing people
well i'll i'll check on the language
there but i think if we're talking about
those who give birth
i think we're talking about uh i i don't
know how else to explain it together
then
it exp i was a little taken back when i
just read it and saw it
that it's that the term mother was gone
in spots and it was replaced with
birthing people
would you at least admit calling a mom a
birthing person
could be offensive to some moms uh that
they don't want to get like a happy
birthing person
card in may or i mean can you at least
admit that
that term itself could be offensive to
some moms
senator i'll go back and take a look at
the the terminology that was used and i
can get back to you but
again if we're trying to be precise in
the language that's used
mom's a pretty good word that's that's
worked for a while and i think that's
pretty precise
we're trying to be precise in the
language that's used you're trying to be
precise
well if you want to be precise you you
would say mother
that's the most precise it's the most
concise way
to describe it but we can't and we are
told
that now the simplest the simplest way
to understand
mothers is as birthing people we're told
that this is a more neutral way a less
offensive way to say because the theory
is
that some men can give birth because the
theory is that some women
can magically become men by wishing and
so because the theory is that our human
person has nothing to do with our bodies
because the theory
is the now popular adoption of the
radical transgender theory which is
a ridiculous ancient heresy
that is not a neutral playing ground
that really matters the the semantic
shift from mother
to birthing person carries with it
whole premises it carries with it a
whole culture
and what xavier becare is trying to say
here is oh you know senator i don't know
i mean i'll go back to the language i
just think come on it's not
it's not a big deal come on it's not a
big deal just
it's we're being precise okay just come
on just
uh and did you hear he he hesitated he
said look i think when we're refer
excuse me mr becerra do are you
referring to mothers here well look i
think it's pretty obvious when we're
referring to birthing people people who
give birth we're referring to
and then he stops himself because he he
he can't say mother
because if he says mother he's admitting
that of course that is the more precise
and concise and direct way to say it but
he can't grant that
because he is beholden to the radical
view
that men can give birth that's what oh
come on who cares who cares you care
buddy you're doing a whole big dance
around to avoid
the plainest simplest most accurate word
you can possibly use
why because of the radical culture
anti-culture that you are bringing
with you hey before you retire
and shut off all of your electronics so
that you can
fully celebrate the feast day the
national feast day of juneteenth the
holiest day of the entire liturgical
calendar
according to the modern libs as of like
five minutes ago
before you do that subscribe ring that
bell
get the notifications head on over to
apple podcasts google play spotify
stitcher wherever you go
get the michael noel show podcast
subscribe leave a five star review and
then most important of all
pre-order speechless controlling words
controlling minds
available now for pre-order head on over
see you next time